Health and Human Services Secretary Alex
Heiser says the window is closing for
the u.s. to get the corona virus under
control he joins us now from Washington
secretary Hayes our good morning as you
just heard the governor of Texas said he
regrets opening bars as quickly as he
did reopening bars as quickly as he did
we've got more than 30 states reporting
rising daily cases as of Friday
secretary mister secretary did America
reopen too soon well here's what we know
which is we're seeing surges in new
cases especially in counties in the
southern United States and our governors
like Governor Abbott are reporting that
the majority of these new cases are
under age 35 many of them are
asymptomatic and we've got to get this
under control because those individuals
can spread this disease even unknowingly
to those who are most vulnerable we all
have got to practice social distancing
we need to wear facial coverings when we
can't social distance and we've got to
engage in appropriate personal hygiene
but one thing that's important for the
people of the country to know is that
our situation is very different than it
was two months ago and in fact we just
made a very important announcement that
President Trump secured half a million
courses of therapy of the drug remedy
severe which is used to treat people
with kovat in the hospital and can
reduce the length of stay by as much as
one-third and we're gonna make sure that
that drug gets to the hospitals that
most need it to take care of American
patients but I want to get to that in a
second mr. secretary but I want to get
to the question of did we open reopen
too fast do you think so we've got to
get back to work back to school and back
to health care and we've seen states
that have reopened just as much as the
counties that are at issue here and have
not seen these kinds of outbreaks we
have to all take personal responsibility
because even within reopening we have
always said the president has said in
his guidelines for reopening practice
social distancing where facial coverings
when you can't and practice good
personal hygiene and if we don't act
responsibly we're gonna see governor's
as did governor Abbott as did governor
Newsom
back on those reopening 'z if we don't
act responsibly but we've got to support
this so we can get our country back up
and running but some states mr.
secretary didn't abide by those
guidelines when they reopen cases we're
still on the rise and they reopened they
started reopening anyway well we can
defer to our states to make the call on
when it's safe to reopen but our
individual behaviors within those
constraints are what's going to drive
whether we see spread of disease because
if we social distance if we protect
ourselves and others by wearing facial
coverings when we can't social distance
we're going to protect not just
ourselves we're going to protect family
members I mean if you have vulnerable
family members at home over 80 are those
who are suffering from key comorbidities
like hypertension diabetes obesity or
kidney failure you're putting them very
much at risk but you know what 40
percent of us are going to be
asymptomatic if we get this disease at
least and that means that when you're at
the grocery store line you could be
actually impacting a vulnerable person
next to you so please practice
appropriate social distancing and
protect others and yourself by wearing
facial coverings when you can't mr.
secretary shouldn't the president be
wearing a mask if we're telling
everybody in the country they should be
wearing a mask so the president's
situation is very different as the
leader of the free world he's the most
tested person probably on earth
everybody who's with him is tested
before they're with him that day he's
he's been kept in a very protected
bubble there so it's a very different
situation he has called for in his own
guidelines from day one for social
distancing and wearing facial coverings
aren't you sending a conflicting signal
it's confusing to people the president
doesn't wear a mask why should i but the
message is very clear and has been from
day one I am his secretary of health I'm
telling you where facial coverings when
you can't social distance the
president's guidelines free openings say
where facial coverings when you can't
social distance so it's been very clear
throughout and it's going to remain
clear you said the window to contain
this virus is closing what did you mean
well because we're seeing so many cases
spread in these counties we've got to
get on them and that means very
localized interventions you know that
the traditional tools of contact tracing
are
but not good enough though that's a
public health official sitting there on
the phone finding who you've been in
touch with but with as much as 40
percent asymptomatic cases we've got to
use tools we use in other types of
public health challenges it actually get
engaged in the community find those
cases but then test everybody in the
community find the cases isolate those
individuals we've used tactics like this
just in the last couple of weeks in
North Carolina in Mecklenburg County
where Charlotte is and it can turn the
tide but it's gonna take local
leadership supported by us and the
states to make that happen
secretary azar thank you so much for
being with us this morning